بخفه ورشاقه وحركات سريعه خطف شاب سوداني
يدعى عبد الله عماد انظار الماره وهو
يستعرض مهاراته بكره القدم امام الجماهير
بسوقي واقف في قطر قبل انطلاق فعاليات كاس
العالم الشاب السوداني كان قد اشتهر عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي قبل سنتين حينما
نشر الحساب الرسمي لنادي برشلونه الاسباني
مقطع فيديو له وهو يلعب بكره القدم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في حادثه غريبه
في مستشفى كفر الشيخ الجامعي الشمالي مصر
مصر وعاقبه سقوتي ممرضه عليه من الطابق
السادس بن- بنفس المستشفى في محاوله
لانهاء حياتها بسبب مرورها باسمه النفسيه
حاده هو توفي
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لرجل امن يفسد لحظه تقدم لاعب كره
قدم للزواج من حبيبته في الملعب فورا
انتهاء المباراه
[موسيقى]
قريه
[تصفيق]
ضجه واسعه عندما اقدمت سيدتنا على انهاء
حياه زوجها وهو نائم فقد اقدمت السيده
بمنطقتي ام درمان على اشاعال النار في
زوجها وهو نائم كثره شكلها برغبته في
الزواج من اخرى حتى لقي مصرعه على الفور
متاثرا بجراحه حسب ما انتشرت صحيفه المشهد
السودانيه مباشره الاجهزه الاجهزه الامنيه
التحقيق بجريمه القتل وتمكنت من القبض على
الزوجه وتحويلها الى المحكمه لاصدار حكم
بحقها
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء